I want you to know where the term statistics comes
from.
Because if you want to remember the word statistic.
Like you, you know the meaning of statistic.
That will even help you.
become more interested in learning the
the formulas
when we are let's go back one second to the concept of sample on
population.
If I can go all the way back here.
Again, remember we we use the sample to get
to the population.
You will get the sample to get to the population.
Now. There is also topic that has to with how you select.
A sample that's called sampling and that's something we will leave
for the Third.
For the third day, okay.
We won't use a sample to know something about
the population. So you want to look we want to look at a small
piece of the story so we can do something about
the entirety of the story.
Well, if you want to learn something about the population using the
sample, there are different things you want to know about the population.
things like standard deviation
Variance mean mode expected
value probably distribution and
on and on and on.
There will be a standard deviation for a population. Like I said.
in a standard deviation, for example
The word mean variance standard deviation expected value
and so on.
these terms
these particular terms
are individually called a statistic.
Okay variance is a statistic mean is a
statistic expected value is a statistic.
well
I I think you can now see where the name
comes from.
right if all we're concerned with if
if we want to know all of these.
things
if you want everything there's still about each and every word you'll love
each and individual statistic when it makes sense to call
the field statistics.
Okay.
So we would use the standard variance to
know something about the population the excuse me. We want to know something
about the sample variance.
to know something about the population variance
You want to know something about the standard expected value
and the sample expected value to know
something about the population?
standard value
If in the content I need to I
need to Define these now because once we get into the exercises
and the examples.
knowing these terminology
It's important. Otherwise, you will be you'll be lost.
If we're talking about a sample.
Like the mean of a sample the variance of a sample.
The expected value of a sample. We call that a statistic.
However, if you're talking about the mean of a population the variance
of a population expect the value of a population we call
that a parameter.
Keep that in mind.